okay so it was a long-ass QA you're
probably going to find a really good
quality version of it somewhere else but
in the meantime I'm going to play some
of the QA that really stood out to me
particularly this one woman who cried
who I almost cried just as she cried
it's like you move and then you couldn't
when I couldn't capture though was I
looked around I was like there's a lot
of other people crying now she's right
it was a weird moment to be like I kind
of wish I was a woman right now so I can
be okay to just cry forever sure I
whizzed everyone instead of four women
in the world
mm-hmm well you know gets exchanged
offering nice finding about sex change
operation let's show these guys show you
guys some footage I know for you wonder
woman with the characters they use the
cloning to work on for a really long
time
have you going to get over that hump of
just saying can I do this can I do this
and just actually getting into it and
making it happen
720 I had been talking about it for so
long I have been talking about it for 10
years
and meeting with them periodically and I
move on and I'm doing something else and
then I had a child they sent me the
script program pregnant like do you want
it now I can't do it right now you know
and so I think this is the duration of
that avails me the opportunity to think
well I love this character and listen
I'm not the only one lot of other people
do too but as the years went on I
thought whoever does this needs to truly
love this character and want to honor
them show
listen I'm idols become the greatest
wealth maker in the world but I'd like
to try and punches anyone and so so by
the time the but I had a very clear
vision for how I wanna go to it and the
kind of movie I wanted to make and you
know I've been around the block enough
that I don't think it's a favor to
anybody to take on a movie if there's a
difference of opinion about that and
then you just fight for here in so if
was magical that I've been saying I
wanted to do it in a certain way and all
these years later Warner Brothers found
themself wanting to do it in the same
way and remember to be obviously and and
we came together in this wonderful
moment great thanks to my producer
Rebecca Romijn their wonderful doubt and
so you know so it sort of half there was
ever any time to really stop and think
about it it was already off to the races
and and I have been saying that for so
long but of course it's like it's super
sobering it's funny because people have
asked me so many questions about was it
intimidating the pressure of being a
woman direct or whatever nothing ever up
lept
the pressure of being the one with the
duty to try to make a great Wonder Woman
and so from day one I was like that is
so important to so many people the way
that Superman want was important to me
and nothing ever superseded that from
the day I took the job what I'm hearing
that perspective on it where I don't
know who's been on social media today or
yesterday but some of these reactions to
the movie are coming out the embargo and
that lifted till 31st but we think about
say how we felt about the movie and I
know you've been paging through all of
them what does it feel like here's a
response listen long may it last but
this is a movie that I I as much as
anyone for people saying nobody's going
to like a movie like that you know four
gears and I'm sorry for anybody all
right right
I couldn't cry myself to see her fan
base show up to see people respond to
the movie in the way that we hoped and
dreamed not everybody will but the
people who are were so grateful for the
support and were so blown away to have
gotten through to somebody anybody
then it got through to to say thank you
so much for supporting what we were
trying to do and I think one for
everyone what comes across so much too
is where you're talking about lying to
have a clear idea of issues there have
been so many different kind of takes
that incarnations of birds throughout
comics and I think it stays very clear
throughout the film the Wonder Woman
that you wanted to create that you
wanted all the fans to get to see good I
love that it makes me super happy I know
you mentioned this before to talk about
it a few times but super in one being
such an inspiration and you guys got to
see that Ally feed in one was appeared
can you talk about how that was kind of
an emotion Superman and what Richard
Donner did in this agreement yeah oh
yeah it was so fun to do that and
there's even another little Martian
movie so I find that to be such a
perfect film because it's dealing with
very adult themes but it could reach
even a child and was very certain to
watch how wonderful to inspire people to
want to be a hero to want to be a better
person
how do you do that look how you learn
how to be a loving wonderful person
while wielding these powers like wow
what a thing so but once in my many
rewatching you know experiences of that
movie that alley scene I love and when
Diana gets demands world complete we
have a moment where Diana's encountering
the problems of man's love and what a
beautiful opportunity to pay a direct
don't watch that scene because it's so
tricky it's Superman why don't those of
you who remember those of you who don't
Superman's in the alley and Lois Lane is
such an amazing character in that movie
with such great dimension
also inspired how we approach Christine
is like now they having a great full
blown wonderful participant in this
story but it's kind of like Superman
she's taking on the mugger and Superman
catches the bullet without her noticing
and then you notice that he's gotten in
his hand so this time I loved the fact
that he said stay back and this show and
then again possible live again and it's
like she's so dummy
so he's like that's awkward but that's
useful tightly uncomfortable for me as a
man but at this moment it's also very
helpful okay go ahead you can protect me
in this moment we can do it together
and I love that about their dynamic like
he's the guy who's like oh this is this
is not exactly something I know how to
deal with but I've been meeting someone
like you so quite some time you know I
don't have that tension between the two
of them exactly I mean every guy needs a
girl who can fend off bullets at any
moment right you have to come over and
get me really quickly yeah oh yeah what
it's like working with working with
everybody on this one and what direction
she gave you but heard there was a
really funny story just starting out
creating the character funny story so
serious I heard that there was a little
like Skype session that went on we did
items I read for the role then Patty and
I Skyped and we spoke for maybe an hour
we quote for a little about character
and then we went off on spiritual things
and we were talking about that we think
purple think people love superhero
movies because it's something that we
want to be and untogether okay so I
think it reminds us that who we really
are so and I think it sort of awakened
magical amazing on negative part in the
world and I cries several times up
invitation you're definitely not alone
in that and I cried in different parts
every time I've seen it suffice
yeah yeah and it was just a lot of fun
and then she said I'm like human curly
ginger wig maker unrecognizable a
beautiful woman and said we put her in
this and you on the first day of
shooting I couldn't believe you were
like I listen so nobody should talk to
me I don't talk to anybody I'm just
going to play this role but yet we're so
amazingly probably one of the most
people I've ever met in my life
oh she just did a t yarn and made me
laugh is so funny you really brought
that character to life so great
I I have had but we need you yes since I
got this role and I will say this two
years of the other pocono has been
magical like something about this movie
for me and I think for a lot of people
who is brought things into our life that
I never such as imagine so I'm really
humbled to be part of it actually I know
a lot of you want to see music some of
the first clips it was like oh my god a
candy I can't wait to see more of her so
I know that everybody here is going to
want to be even more ahead of getting
even with the red ginger curly wig we're
all in college I'm not a comic book
person and I'm not an action film person
I'm a comedian and I made awkward comedy
videos on YouTube and I I was so I mean
somebody had a really important time for
winter sighs excited by the message of
the movie and excited by who he was in
Freeman and showing it being a kind of
man actually just makes you stronger
I'm so inspired by her message her
inability to sit passively behind and
talked it for my niece's to see it I
really believe that there are messages
of love healing that has been told of
course in so many other stories across
so clearly here and I do believe it's
going to be a blockbuster
I do believe it's going to be I have so
many questions but like I want like take
you to coffee and like you know much I
mean that I cannot tell you what it
means to me with people like all of you
like when you say that because I
couldn't agree with you more and about
the world and and I feel like you know
that was part of the duty that was put
in my lap was like god it's time for a
new kind of hero as well which is like
to be a hero is not easy and it's not
simple and it's not bad it's over it's
unbelievably complicated and it's going
to require us being better people
and all I mean don't get me started on
this but I could go on on twice you're
serious about the fact that this is the
story of maybe of a company someone
we've relate with taking the journey to
learn to be a hero and realizing it is
so difficult and not you're not always
even able to save people who deserve it
in fact you're saving a lot of people
who don't deserve it and why do you do
it then because that's what you believe
and like if we all don't become a hero
we are not gonna be able to save this
world because there's nobody coming and
so it means all of us and particularly
in the day and age of the Internet and
the day and age of like different
countries colliding and different kinds
of people if we don't become accountable
and like challenge ourselves to be more
loving and thoughtful with our power
because we all are powerful then we're
not going to save the world and so that
was where when I have Diana sitting in
my hand who stands for love and truth
and beauty and I'm saying I can I can I
didn't try to say something in this
world about life it wasn't what I
thought it was going to be to be a hero
instead it
other harder less lawyers choice so for
you in the non superhero fan to feel
that experience which I cared about very
much too and always saying like I want
to make great superhero movie and I also
want make some beautiful movies that's
it that takes advantage of that to say
something that means so much to me I
won't forget what you said tonight
thank you I'm sorry I got you my
favorite
it is there something about so sparkly
people question like an option zoom up
it assumes guys get right like this is a
hold of them zoomin hits like a this is
a copy of a call to action they I would
love that
yeah with love is if it became a call to
action to people being a gyro themselves
I would love it and little girls and
little boys and everybody maybe
questioning themselves when they have a
chance to make it would change I mean he
could change the lunch yes you know and
I'm commuting you're not alone and I
feel like because every time I spent
time around like and seeing the movie
and having those good words like within
the first five minutes of the movie I
was like what is on my face right now
like I literally like just tears like
not ugly hears or to places like perfect
now my cheek and I'm like it's because
you want it like that I think it's a
Karate Kid there was no movie like that
for girls when you get to see this
little girl fighting it wants to be like
part of the group and then seeing all
these women come together it is so
emotional whether you're a comic book
fan or not and and I'm glad that you
know you're getting to do this be Morgan
person not the same
so I know we've got another question
back there what's your name what's your
question hate it and I was wondering
like honestly inside out how the
wonderful minute they soon will have to
pop on young girls or boys out there
that uses lot so just to have I think
it's a look it's taking from what I said
which is like you're the hero and I need
you not the use that could be I mean you
right now and so every time you face a
choice taking responsibility because
it's what you believe that I'm going to
make the rectum nobody may know it and
it might not even be the easy thing to
do or it might not whatever I think
maybe it silently right now myself
because that's what I believe that
that's the number one thing and the
number two thing is like yes that is
that is that is that everybody in this
lifetime cases Jenna me to being a hero
themselves no matter who they are and so
hoping that little boys and little girls
everywhere who see it feel like a hero
for that night then it inspires everyone
in that thank you
you have an eight-year-old son and it
rocks my world his relationships to
YouTube and like all of the kids that he
goes to school with this is it this is
one whole world and like to watch like
dantdm be like the Messiah of white his
school in England what we're living
there and every kid there I'm like oh my
god and and a great guy thank God you
know but the influence that show many
people on YouTube like this you know
excites me the most there was a period
of time I stopped watching drama
complete
because I was like I saw a washing
reality TV and my attitude was do a
better job man and I'll watch it but
like this is dry and played out and
wanna watch these real people talk to
each other and like a survivor you know
like I'm going to aqua because at least
I was getting like life yeah real life
and I and I felt like it was under such
a stranglehold of like with big things
like dictating something this has
changed the world like YouTube is
changing the world in the fact that like
everything I said about story in human
experience human experience living human
experience so like I know you guys know
this this is what you do but like don't
stop believing in the power of your
experience no matter how low by it is
like that's nothing buh-bye
I thought I recognized this uses do
something on stage by yourself with no
nothing and you know I've seen people do
those shows and and have a huge impact
on in theater so it's like it's
incredible what you guys are doing and I
ask you all to like - don't take it
lightly what you guys can do you know
don't take it lightly
even if you're separate that do right
thank you guys so much I love
so I would love to get a selfie with
Patti and whole audience doing their
power pose
okay guys I'm going to do that yeah all
right thank you guys